[Applause]
it is my great pleasure to welcome all
of you to Columbia's first world Leaders
Forum event
of this academic year we are joined this
afternoon by the prime minister of
Bhutan Prime Minister Tinley Prime
Minister we are delighted that you were
able to be with us Columbia's world
leaders forum was launched in 2003 as a
university-wide initiative for the
purpose of supporting uninhibited
dialogue on the most pressing economic
political environmental and social
questions of our time questions that
with each passing year have increasingly
larger and larger global dimensions and
we take it as an article of faith here
that the free exchange of ideas will be
the best way to find remedies to the
biggest problems we face by allowing the
university community to enter into
discussions with leaders who are
grappling with major challenges on the
international stage the world leaders
forum allows Colombia to fulfill one of
its most important duties as a global
center of learning and research the
address we will hear today from Prime
Minister tin Lai is titled well-being
happiness and leadership I feel
confident in saying that no other guest
could possibly be as well equipped to
address this subject Bhutan is home to a
unique civil society one that for more
than 30 years has been defined largely
by the nation's focus on maximizing
gross national happiness rather than the
typical goal of increasing gross
national product prime minister tin Lai
was elected in the country's first
national
in March 2008 prior to the introduction
of democracy to Bhutan he served the
previous government in several
capacities including as Minister for
Foreign Affairs and Minister for Home
and Cultural Affairs he has spoken on
numerous occasions at sessions of the
United Nations General Assembly and last
year the King of Bhutan awarded the
Prime Minister the nation's highest
civilian honor having first joined
Bhutan civil service in 1974 the Prime
Minister's adult life has been
inseparably intertwined with the modern
history of Bhutan now the Prime Minister
finds himself leading Bhutan through a
period of extraordinary transition just
over a decade ago in 1999 television and
the Internet were introduced to Batak in
2008 the nation held its first
democratic election two years after the
king voluntarily abdicated his throne
and ordered that the monarchy be
replaced with a constitutional democracy
while it is certainly true that
globalization has thrust changes of
great magnitude upon many nations and
that the introduction of modern
communications technologies and the
spread of democratic governance are
posing challenges for many societies
futons experience informed by its
commitment to gross national happiness
is unique to enhance gross national
happiness Bhutan focuses on what it
calls the four pillars the economy the
culture the environment and good
government today the Bhutanese are
evaluating the adoption of modern
technology and democratic practices
within this distinctive framework the
lessons from this transition will be
instructive not only for the people of
Bhutan
but for all the people of the world in
the months ahead we will all be watching
therefore with great interests as the
events unfold in Bhutan it is a set of
circumstances that has no parallel
elsewhere in the world today except that
would only add this Colombia is widely
known for many things but it is known as
the happiest University in the United
States all you have to do is see the
students on the steps as you walk in
here and just realize how happy a place
this is so mr. prime minister you have
come to the right place in the United
States to address us I am now pleased to
introduce Bhutan's prime minister tin
lay our first guest of this year's world
leaders forum mr. prime minister thank
you
[Applause]
thank you very much president Bollinger
Jean Bollinger professor Jeffrey Sachs
Friends of Bhutan fellow countrymen
ladies and gentlemen I am honored to be
invited to speak at the world leaders
forum here on the happy and hallowed
grounds of this renowned institution the
cradle of great minds nurtured by some
of the most erudite mentors on the
planet among these I respectfully
acknowledge my friends professor Jeffrey
Sachs and hosted Stiglitz who is
represented by his wife Anna to begin
with I would like you to know that it is
perfectly understandable if a few among
you are not aware of where in the world
my little country is situated many years
ago before the advent of Google Maps I
suffered the frustration of explaining
to an American grad student where it is
when I mentioned our contiguous
neighbors India and China she wasn't
sure where these two third-world
countries were finally I thought of the
great Himalayas and described how it
lies within its protective folds to my
relief she smiled and declared that she
would never have guessed I came from
Africa
so if any of you wish to know where
Bhutan is of late the country is a
little better known having become a
subject of curiosity for the way in
which our development process in the
last three and a half decades has been
guided by the philosophy of gross
national happiness G and H is based on
the belief that the purpose of
development and the role of the state is
to create conditions within which people
can pursue and find what they aspire for
most in life happiness it is a holistic
development paradigm to make human
society resilient it motivates an
individual and society to consciously
balance material wants with spiritual
growth wherein the needs of the body and
those of the mind are addressed in equal
measure within a stable and sustainable
environment while many happiness
indicators please Bhutan high in the
listing what I can quite safely claim is
that we are the only country so far that
promotes happiness through deliberate
public policy and action I'm here in New
York to participate in the high-level
segment of the UN GA at which the world
leaders will deliberate on the progress
of countries and the world in general on
the eight Millennium Development Goals
for Bhutan the pursuit of MDGs is a part
of the national effort to create the
enabling conditions for happiness but it
is not very likely that there will be
cause for joy at the global level at the
United Nations this year the progress
worldwide has
unacceptably low to use a phrase of the
secretary-general yet as many of you
will agree the attainment of MDGs is in
fact a minimalist requirement in any
society indeed most of the goals are
survival indicators which every country
must achieve that is why when we are
confronted with the knowledge that there
are countries which may not realize any
of the goals
it is truly disconcerting for this
reason it will not be with much pride
that Bhutan will on its part report that
it is well on track and that it will
accomplish certain goals well before the
target year of 2015 the special
significance of the UN summit this year
for my country is that after some quiet
encouragement by Professor Jeff Sachs
special advisor to the MDGs to the
United Nations secretary-general my
delegation will propose the inclusion of
happiness as the ninth Millennium
Development Goal
[Music]
we believe that the world's increasing
understanding of the consequences of
having allowed ourselves to be misguided
by GDP into an unsustainable and
self-destructive Way of life has created
the environment for the inclusion of
this universal and timeless indicator
however I do not intend to dwell on this
subject here today as it is the world
leaders forum that I have the honor to
address I thought it appropriate to
sketch from a particular perspective the
nature of leadership itself and the
challenges that all leaders must
inevitably face
I believe that Western society as a
whole is in the process of interpreting
or rather reinterpreting and indeed
recasting its concepts of both the good
life and a good economy this is sending
beneficial ripples of Awakening and a
new consciousness across the world in
the years ahead
we in the developing countries will
learn much from you with special
interest as you undertake a
reorientation of democratic politics and
economic democracy in the direction of a
more peaceful equitable and sustainable
way of life our common challenges call
for a kind of leadership that has the
vision will an ability to reorient
society as communities as nations and as
a species that is threatened by its own
actions the gathering momentum of global
problems that deprives us of the luxury
of time to come up with solutions is
what must weigh heavily on the minds of
leaders and ought to stimulate their
creativity they need to be prepared to
listen to even the radical thoughts
today and accept the possibility that
these may well become the dogma or
tomorrow in our search for solutions to
the multiplicity of problems that
confront society leaders must be able to
rise above ideological historical and
economic fault lines that divide our
world they will need to find new ways to
create a more harmonic world how common
understanding and cohesive ideas can be
forged among disparate minds and Nations
against the paradox of globalization
will test leadership as never before
coming from the Himalayas and the
Himalayan Buddhist culture as I do I
cannot resist citing the age-old notions
of leadership stemming from the Buddhist
worldview that was earlier dominant in
the Himalayan societies I realized that
the relevance of such a worldview will
naturally be questioned we have always
believed that a leader is someone who
possesses three mutually reinforcing
qualities these are compassion knowledge
and strength it is these three qualities
balanced in their composition and
application that transform and propel
ordinary people to rise above the
ordinary for the good of society
separately each of these qualities have
little meaning knowledge and strength
are by themselves dangerous the
knowledge of a leader must be stinked
especially in the pattern of existential
suffering so likewise strength must mean
will and capacity to alleviate suffering
these need to be motivated and tempered
by compassion and a deep understanding
of suffering not only for
humans but all sentient beings the
striving of aspirants to gain these
intrinsic but to cultivable qualities
cultivable qualities give them public
recognition and acceptance as the
leaders there is no doubt that the forms
and extent of suffering from
psychological to the relational from
physical to the mental will always
remain an inseparable part of human
condition but a leader must be aware
that the power and potential to overcome
them are equally present in all of us
the way a leader acts to remove
suffering and raises the consciousness
and capacity to do so in others is a
primary yardstick of leadership the
Himalayan notion of leadership is
therefore extremely broad and embraces
the highest human values growing as it
does far beyond the much narrower
principles and practices of conventional
management science and practices the
good thing about the quality of
compassion is that much like the muscles
it can be built toned and strengthened
and likewise if it does not receive the
benefit of exercise it will gradually a
trophy and disappear more precisely
compassion can be obscured and
suppressed by negative emotions the
approach to generating this quality is
in consciously and purposefully breaking
the barriers that separate us from being
concerned about others and being
sensitive to their suffering
this kid's been taking a little bit of
water
it would thus seem that compassion
development would be an essential
ingredient to be fused into modern
leadership training in a world of
increasing professional and specialized
expertise the leader can certainly not
be omniscient but these are the three
qualities through which she will be able
to provide Direction inspiration and
stewardship let me now shift from this
brief discussion on the ingredients of
leadership to some of the regional
problems to the resolution of which
these qualities may be applied they are
big in scale and multi-generational in
scope search for their solutions demand
multidisciplinary approaches and
visualization of their effects as may
unfold over decades and far beyond as
they are extensions of global problems
they will not be unfamiliar to you
Colombian students and so my motive is
in no way to undermine your knowledge
but simply to remind so as to arouse
your compassion and strengthen
strengthen your determination to
alleviate suffering inciting an account
of some of these problems I shall put
them in the context of their
consequences on well-being and happiness
these being the primary concerns of good
leaders first there is the continuing
explosion of populations that will go
well into the 2050s the two giants China
and India will bulge to become
demographically obese in the meanwhile
the aged population will have grown in
Japan China Korea Singapore and others
in hot pursuit
even the young Bhutanese population will
no longer be youthful in the next 25
years presenting acute challenges for
the care and financing of the elderly as
in the aging North it will become
progressively difficult to ensure the
well-being of elderly people especially
as the responsibility for caregiving
will shift rapidly from family to the
state from the natural to the artificial
and the unsustainable this would be a
fundamental departure from and in market
contrast to our tradition throughout our
history the elderly received respectful
care in the extended family and its
network which they themselves nurtured
in their productive and able days the
extended family in fact has always been
the cornerstone of our community and
society but it is now being shaken loose
by the seismic changes of modernization
and urbanization instead of veneration
the aged are being edged out to the
margins of society and sadly in families
where the good tradition survives the
caregivers themselves are already
experiencing the frailty of life while
most of those who need care will be over
80 years many who push their wheelchairs
provide hot meal meals and give home
comfort will be pensioners beyond 60
years of age as more and more people are
drawn to the urban setting and lifestyle
migration dislocation and breakdown of
community and social bonds will be on
the rise in today's urban and work
dominated life community integrity
social life and the elderly are the
primary victims
these make a compelling case for the
need to regenerate social bonds and
revitalize communities as a prerequisite
to happiness to begin with innovative
policies and programs to motivate and
facilitate your graphic dispersal of
habitation are options that merit
consideration social support and
participation for the elderly is one of
the most important enablers of aging
with grandeur and happiness as must be
old age must come with reverence and
gratitude from loved ones and the young
must receive the benefit of its
boundless affection and wisdom the
establishment of such conditions call
for actions
far beyond financial arrangements yet
the cost of inaction is just too severe
to contemplate it must thus be the
endeavor of compassionate leaders to
create environments wherein aging comes
without fear of insecurity and pain of
loneliness the good news it is that for
many countries and their leaders time
affords them the opportunity to
anticipate plan and act and for the
elderly societies there are options that
good leadership knowledge can find when
motivated by compassion and undertaken
with strength of purpose and conviction
second the rate of our biodiversity loss
is slowing down or is it
well it isn't it is accelerating both on
surface and in water and with the
disappearance of each species of plant
insect bird or animal Homo sapiens inch
closer to its own extinction going by
the current trends biodiversity
destruction will continue in tandem with
the expansion of monoculture cropping
deforestation excessive fish fishing
greenhouse gas emissions pollution of
air and water etc the dramatic loss of
biodiversity is a clear evidence of our
failure to live in harmony with nature
it is an unmistakable sign that in
systematically abusing nature to appease
our insatiable cravings we are
destroying our very source of sustenance
leaders must have knowledge of the
higher truth that all life-forms are
interrelated and that it is the harmony
and vitality of our interdependence
which will ensure mutual survival we are
but only one of the inhabitants of this
planet and as the most dominant we have
the burden of greater responsibility the
loss of biodiversity is not to be
understood as the extinction of this or
that species but the severance of
relationships towards mutually assured
destruction from this point of view the
toleration of ecological destruction is
unconscionable and questions the
intelligence and rationality of human
society
from all that we have seen and witnessed
it will require tremendous strength of
leadership founded on compassion for
those affected and for the sake of our
future generations to overcome the
foolishly powerful with resistance to
the knowledge based solutions that will
no doubt have huge costs but will ensure
a long-term survival and well-being
third our persistent reliance on
inefficient fossil fuel dependent
technologies and wasteful consumption
continue to destabilize climate and
environment The effect of climate change
especially in agriculture is adding new
and mounting challenges to the health
and indeed survival of the largest
section of our regional population the
rural farmers in the most extreme cases
crop failures have literally meant end
of life for many families with tens of
thousands being driven to suicide that
so literally should be written and
spoken about this by leaders and by the
media is a reflection of the lack of
interest in critical knowledge and a
shameful deficit of compassion the slow
erosion and the submergence of fertile
and densely populated coastal regions
and the dying of the rivers are the
drawing of the rivers and lakes with
devastating consequences for all forms
of life our poignantly tragic more so
for the reason that these are
conceivably avoidable
the stern review has estimated that
investment to the order of 1% of global
GDP per year in new technologies is the
bare minimum necessary to stem emissions
we all know that GDP or income per
capita is not equally distributed over
the globe but the reasoning that
emissions per capita is not equally
distributed across the globe must not be
used as moral justification to pollute
more and stand against the need to build
consensus on the need to take remedial
action or to undertake investment in new
technologies humanity has no choice
and such justifications cannot change
that reality but even if we were to make
appreciable gains in the development and
application of new technologies the dire
need to rein in our consumerist fashion
and to reduce wasteful consumption by
the richer sections of our society will
not diminish learning to live better
with less is entirely possible and
responsible leaders must aspire to pave
a new path to living well without greed
being the determining factor and
material possessions being the
definition of status and success could
we not change perceptions whereby
excessive consumption becomes
conspicuous and embarrassing could we
not dignify simple and responsible
living for example while we continue to
develop and make affordable energy
efficient and non fossil fuel dependent
vehicles we could learn to move more on
the soles of our feet and make it
socially an admirable and a desirable
thing to do as in fact I must appreciate
many in New York in fact do in the same
vein I'm using a computer have now lost
my the hazards of modern technology for
an ancient civilization like that of
Bhutan to which I belong I'll find it
in the same vein we would convince
ourselves of the virtue of localizing
food production localizing food
production and routing material needs in
the immediacy of our surroundings data -
is the need to redefine well-being that
will enable sustained happiness as a
timeless human endeavor but we need to
do so in quite different ways from the
way we are used to a variety of market
and non-market measures has to be taken
agent Lee given that we cannot depend
solely on the market for investment into
new technologies as the Stern Review
mentions there are no markets with rates
of return for public investment
decisions over a period as long as 100
years the review mentions that the key
mistake made by economists in the past
working on the economics of climate
change was to use market discount rate
one would hope that switching to new
technologies will not prove too
unaffordable for low-income countries
coordinated international policies must
ensure they become accessible on a wider
basis but if the transfer of new
technologies is seen merely as another
way of shifting global income and
prosperity they will not spread rapidly
and evenly at the same time I'm hopeful
that the industrial competition for
scarce resources such as rare metals and
rare earth for the manufacture of
electrical engines and other
revolutionary technologies do not
undermine peace and stability fourth the
relentless growth of the weapons
industry an increasing expenditure on
weapons based security and military
personnel
continue to divert resources from human
well-being related development the same
nineteenth-century logic of security
arrangement cooperation and alliance
gives a sense of security to some while
forcing others to follow the same logic
in an atmosphere of relative and
comparative insecurity I think it is
possible for us to realize that it is
not security
but insecurity we create by the spread
of arms and expansion of armies the
persistence of security blocks and the
weapons industry are a major obstacle to
the emergence of a new consciousness of
belonging to one planet with common
stakes and a shared destiny would it be
too bold for me to advocate a departure
from the old logic of security to move
to a future of non adversarial security
system whereby legions of peace
guardians are maintained at regional
peace centers where gradually
decommissioning of the military and real
disarmament are undertaken wooded with
childish naivety on my part to dream of
such legions equipped and trained in
completely non-conventional and
non-military ways of non-violence non
confrontation and conciliation fifth the
juxtaposition of unhealthy lifestyles
and strivings for longer life has
resulted in the intensification of
healthcare enabled by the allocation of
an increasing amount of personal income
and state revenue to Medicare but long
life is not necessarily worthwhile not
for the rising number and proportion of
people whose extended life means
prolongation of loneliness and suffering
of painful indignities how do we as a
society here and respond to the call for
the restoration of vital and venerable
old age by those who banished to the
fringes of society are too afraid to die
and too fearful to wake up each day here
I must allude to GNH which has so much
to do with promoting a successful cycle
of birth' living aging and dying this is
not a matter of individual choice it is
within the broader context of favourable
structures that are happy and healthy
life mentally and physically can be
enjoyed the quality of life is
determined not by individual
circumstances alone but substantially by
the structural conditions of society
which we collectively create to be born
successful means zero infant and
maternal mortality but being born well
into a rich family and physical
environment is not everything to grow
and to be raised well children need good
Parenthood a good neighborhood
creative education and so forth these
kinds of social capital are depreciating
significantly across the world
especially in urban areas successful
living means having a contributory
fulfilling and meaningful work life not
simply earning to consume or saving for
old age we find from our genic surveys
in Bhutan that it is at the peak of our
health say from 35 to 45 years of age
when we should be enjoying ourselves
that the curve of subjective well-being
dips and bottoms out
therein lies a serious case for
restructuring our five-day nine-to-five
working week it is not conceivable
rather inconceivable to have 25 hours a
week of work a week of intensive
intensively creative and productive work
and pursue diverse interests for the
remaining part of the week to become
whole again and to be rejuvenated
this would allow among other things the
spread of employment and income more
leisure time for everybody and
physically and a physically and mentally
healthy population the pressure to work
hard in the middle section of our life
to be financially successful before we
swiftly reach our pensionable age is
indeed too grim and brutal in this
regard I felt encouraged by the recent
UK government decision which states that
employers cannot pension off people at
65 if they choose to keep working ladies
and gentlemen I have shared my thoughts
on the Himalayan view of what makes good
leaders and likewise I have outlined
some of the current and future
challenges that a leader will inevitably
face I have touched briefly on the need
for us to redefine the purpose of life
and meaning of well-being so that our
pursuits in life and the way we organize
our society and create its values are in
conformity in other words I have dwelt
on some of the main concerns that must
be addressed in the course of
development that aims to promote a happy
and a contented society the
contemplation of the impermanence of
self and
others just like a good pilgrim on a
journey does is a useful engagement for
any leader it is one of the Eastern
routes a Himalayan one for a leader to
transform towards a higher ground
of broad global awareness and knowledge
and to be guided by a sense of
compassion that generates the strength
to act not only within the sphere of
one's direct responsibility but the
benefit of all sentient beings after all
as I've said before ours is an
interdependent world of shrinking space
diminishing resources and mounting
challenges for our collective survival I
thank you for the gracious floor that
you have given me and for your kind
invitation mr. president Thank You Tashi
Delek
[Applause]
mr. Prime Minister I know I speak for
all of us in expressing gratitude for
such a remarkable talk this is not
exactly the day daily fair that we're
hearing in our campaign season here and
so you've given us an opportunity to
quietly open our eyes and minds and the
brains to the wisdom that you're
bringing and it's my great pleasure to
open the floor now for questions we have
a few minutes with the prime minister
for Q&A and then we have a reception
afterwards so we have wonderful
opportunity as a group for some
discussion and then in individual
exchange afterwards so I would request
that people that would like to ask a
question there are two microphones when
you come up please make it a question
make it brief and before asking the
question introduce yourself if you would
maria sadaqa Graduate School of
Journalism mr. prime minister
I would like you to explain what do you
do you see a value in free speech and
freedom of expression and free press in
reaching those goals of all common
happiness in the world and
democratization of your country thank
you us at all because Jeffrey was going
to be here so the questions that I
cannot answer he will answer also now I
discover I might need him to perhaps I
couldn't hear your question so perhaps
yes okay I will repeat do you think that
freedom of press and freedom of
expression are the elements of the road
to overall happiness which we need to
pursue and what's the role of Free Press
you see for your country and I'm from
graduate school of journalism okay thank
you thank you
I think I can manage that very important
I think it's one of the most critical
elements and in fact in one of the
recent publications research
publications it has been reported that
freedom is a major contributing factor
to people feeling happy feeling secure
and and so likewise in the case of
Bhutan a country that pursues happiness
the freedom of the media the freedom of
the press is very very important to the
extent that my government has gone on
record for having publicly stated that
it is not just three branches of
government that we have but four
branches of governance and the fourth is
the media we feel that in an emerging
democracy such as ours the media has to
play an important role so that it
becomes well established so that it
remains irreversible and so as much as
possible
we are trying to give and provide
resources to them to the media without
in any way interfering with their
independence and separateness thank you
hi my name is Joel and I'm an I'm an
undergraduate at Columbia and you
mentioned that a good leader should have
compassion for all sentient beings and
I'm wondering if gross domestic
happiness includes animals as well and
if so how do you judge if an animal is
happy or not very difficult question
I'm not too sure whether we have any
kind of means yet devised to measure the
happiness level of animals but what we
do know is that animals insects birds
require need their space as well in
order that they can function and they
can survive and live as they are meant
to as equal members and owners of this
planet and so Bhutan today because we
have been pursuing the philosophy the
policy of gross national happiness
Bhutan today happens to be despite being
as small as it is a country that has
been admired among others by the World
Wide Fund for Nature we have here an
ex-president of WWF here which
recognized Bhutan as one of the hotspots
of biodiversity a country with
tremendous biodiversity and that
continues to be so and one of the first
things that my government did upon being
elected to govern was to expand the the
protected area in Bhutan and today 51%
of Bouton's territory is falls under
protected area and also having assisted
with this philosophy this development
philosophy Bhutan today is becoming
greener and not browner
despite demographic growth despite
agricultural expansion urbanization and
industrialization today we have 72
percent of forest cover while the
Constitution requires that for all times
Bhutan must have a minimum of 60% of
forest
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is David aboon I'm a freshman at
Columbia College and I was awesome I was
I went to school in the Himalayas also
and a lot of my friends were Bhutanese
and so my question for you is why if
Bhutan is so committed to this idea of
gross national happiness why so many of
its elite and so many of its people in
general must leave Bhutan to be educated
elsewhere and why Bhutan has not done
more for to give more opportunities for
those who want to be educated in Bhutan
if you're talking about Bhutanese
students studying in here in the United
States it just happens to be because
this country has the best educational
institutions the best systems the best
mentors in the world and we want a bit
of that it's not just in not just in the
United States but in India as well like
the where I went to school and where you
yes it's true in India in Australia in
in many Anglophone countries and that
will continue to be so one thing is that
Bhutan wants to benefit from the
diversity of educational resources that
are spread across the world while at the
same time you know you have to remember
that Bouton's
development process has been very slow
very methodical as was necessary for a
country in pursuit of happiness wanting
to ensure that equilibrium balances were
not disturbed that culture and values
were not in any way disrupted we had to
go slowly and today let me tell you that
we will be among the first lesser
developed countries to achieve universal
primary enrolment and our university and
institutions of higher learning continue
to grow and expand but among all our
budgetary allocations for various
sectors education receives the highest
human resource development is a priority
and even as educational institutions in
our country continue to grow we will
ensure that our students through
government scholarship and through the
support of various developing countries
will receive access to institutions such
as happy Colombia
thank you from the School of Public
Health thank you so much for sharing
with us today
I was curious when you use happiness as
a measure does that interfere or
complicate doing different health
interventions that might be helpful
maybe to 2% of the population but if the
whole population then has to go through
testing is that when I'm making some
sense
hmm well so far the provision of basic
and essential health services providing
comprehensive our efforts to provide
comprehensive basic health care service
in Bhutan has never really been in
conflict with our policy of you know as
well the the paradigm of day and age but
I imagine that as we go along as our
society becomes more and more
sophisticated as our health capacity
grows and develops there will be
questions and issues of the kind that
you raise of the kind that your modern
society your advanced society are faced
with but presently there hasn't been
difficulties and for instance if we were
to talk about AIDS and HIV for instance
the incidence level is very low the
total number of HIV infected people in
our country as reported thus far is only
168 but we are not complacent
and the government ensures that they
each of them has direct state provided
support to aintry antiretroviral
retroviral medication and the state also
has a policy whereby since we don't know
how the larger population may react
while a lot of advocacy is being done so
that people know the you know the
content the implications of the state of
this disease we maintain absolute
confidentiality as to the identity of
those people who are infected
hi it's Ryan I'm a master's of computer
science here and I'm just wondering if
you feel that there's any impact of
buddhist teaching on gross national
happiness i'm going to ask of the
buddhist philosophy is there any
connection between that and gross
national happiness you mentioned that
yours is a buddhist society i do believe
that there are many Buddhist scholars
here so they can help me with this with
this with this question but let me tell
you that Gross National Happiness is a
philosophy that was conceived by our
King who is often referred to as a
Dharma King a Buddhist King and our
entire culture happens to be steeped and
founded on Bhutanese values and the
teachings of the of the Dharma and for
instance even when I spoke of the three
qualities of leadership with compassion
being the most important we are talking
about Buddhist values Buddhist ethos and
one of the things that Buddhism teaches
us is detachment to control one's greed
you know and so on and and these are
very much you know in harmony with
rather these are the values on which the
development paradigm of Bhutan is
founded no conflict at all but if
anybody wishes to elaborate on this I
would like to learn hi I'm Camille from
the school of international public of
Camille from the School of International
and public affairs and you mentioned
that one of the characteristics of a
good leader is compassion and you also
mention that security and spending on
defense takes away from human
development how do you see these two
aspects play a role in countries that
face security concerns through prolonged
conflicts
well as I said one of the first thing we
do is a decommission our military and
close down our weapons manufacturing but
that would be too naive as I said but as
I said in my in my in my address you
know even the most radical of thoughts
and ideas today may become the dogma of
tomorrow and I think as young people as
as future leaders of this and many
countries that you represent I think you
have to be daring you have to build your
vision of a better country and and you
do so by asking the kind of questions
that that that you do I welcome that
question in my own country the military
is not an important organ of state it is
more a ceremonial in a an organization
that has ceremonial functions but at
times there are occasions when it does
need to play a military role but it is
our hope that not too far in the distant
future we will be able to create
organizations for the maintenance of
peace and security that will not require
the use of weapons of destruction
[Applause]
Prime Minister you've given us a lot to
think about and I hope our SEPA students
also can take your challenge and think
about in your region the fact that the
military spending in Afghanistan is
about 10 times the country's national
income each year and yet the situation
deteriorates in that country rather than
improve so how to turn something so
large economically but so futile into
something more promising I think is
really the prime minister's message we
have to listen very closely to what you
said and to ponder it I take a note of
comfort in the fact that our country was
founded also on a claim of a inalienable
right to life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness so we have in our tradition
also a stake hold in this idea I think
there are many of us who feel we're
losing our way right now and the wisdom
that you've brought today I think can
help us find a way to that path so on
behalf of Columbia University the
happiest University in the United States
for good reason the wonderful leadership
of our president and a a remarkable
student body let me thank you Prime
Minister for being here
you